I am not taking ParaClear due to my Walnut allergy. Should I be addressing parasites in other
ways? So first of all, let's address this. Would a person with a Walnut allergy be sensitive
to ParaClear because it has a Walnut whole extract? Yes, maybe. I told this person just
to omit that right now because I don't want you having some allergic reaction to that. You've got
enough changes in your life at this point. We can test that later on. So I would say,
no, you're safe to just leave that out right now. Should we add something else to add to parasites?
Now, another person, I may say yes, but this person who asked this question, I said, no, let's wait
because my concern was you had just so many changes, so many things going on, so many things
turning at the same time. Let's just pause that for a second. We can come back to that. We don't even
have your mosaics down. We don't have everything done. We don't have all the data in. Let's just wait
out of that. So I would say, let's just wait out of that, especially if you're starting chemo. Let's just
pause that for a right now. We don't want to add too many juggling balls at the same time.